I have come to this building every day and done my job. Three decades I've given to this office.
But honestly sometimes it scares me. I don't know what we do here
Have I done something wrong?
Someone walked in from the other side. The other side I...  Whatever you do, don't panic.
Wai..Wha...Hi Howard
Lee do you have any idea how lucky you are?  No one, No one gets to meet other.  Other?
Thirty years ago during the Cold War there was an experiment.
Something went wrong.  They opened up a passage.
When you go through this door you come out the other side. You're in another world identical to ours.
There was one reality and then it duplicated.
We share genetics, childhood.  I want to know how you became so different.
Shhh.
A kill order came out from my side targeting people on your side.
Handle is Baldwin. She's a contract assassin.  Your wife may be her next target.
We're caught in the middle of something whether we want to be or not.  We should just build a wall and never come back.
They hate your side for what you've done to ours.
You don't know these people like I do.   They don't tolerate mistakes
The last thing you want is me with nothing left to say.